بعد قطر شمس المونديال لعام 2026 ستشرق من
القاره الامريكيه ضمن نسخه ستكون
استثنائيه بكل المقاييس تعود من خلالها
اجواء المونديال الى بلد العم سام بعد
غياب استمر لاكثر من 28 عاما النسخه
الثالثه والعشرون من كاس العالم ستكون
مختلفه عن سابقاتها بحيث ستنظم على اراضي
ثلاثه بلدان وهي الولايات المتحده وكندا
والمكسيك التي تسجل رقما قياسيا باستضافه
حدث البطوله للمره الثالثه فبعد اربع
سنوات تتوجهوا انظروا عشاق الساحره
المستديره الى القاره الامريكيه التي
ستحتضن المشجعين والوفود المشاركه حيث
يرتفع عدد المنتخبات المشاركه الى 48 لاول
مره في تاريخ المونديال
بدلا من 32 فريقا كما هو المعتاد ولاول
مره في تاريخ كاس العالم والتي ستكون
مقسمه على 16 مجموعه وفي كل مجموعه ثلاثه
منتخبات
وستشهد البطوله اقامه 80 مباراه اي بزياده
16 مباراه مقارنه بكاس العالم الذي اقيم
هذا العام في قطر حيث شهد اقامه 64 مباراه
وستجري تلك المباريات في 16 ملعبا بحيث
ستقام المباريات في 11 مدينه امريكيه منها
بوستن واتلانتا وكنسه وهيوسن ولومي فيما
ستستضيف ثلاث مدن مكسيكيه واثنتان كنديتين
المباريات الباقيه